there are no talks scheduled to end the
shutdown President Trump who's
complained of never leaving the White
House flew to New Orleans yesterday to
speak to a farmers convention he
returned just in time to welcome college
football's new national champions to a
White House reception where fast food
was on the menu Paula Reid is at the
White House with more on this story Paul
everybody knows McDonald's french fries
are the best here at the White House and
while the impact of the shutdown is
increasingly being felt across the
country
here at the White House it has some
political advantages first of all it has
helped delivering on this longtime trump
goal of constraining the federal
government and it's also helping to
distract from the ever expanding Russia
investigation President Trump well he's
loving it we have some wonderful people
working at the White House they helped
us out with this quarter pounders by
candlelight with Whitehouse residential
staff furloughed president Trump picked
up the tab for burgers pizza and fries
for the champion Clemson Tigers I will
say the Republicans are really really
sticking together it's great to see
because we need border security we have
to have it but both sides may just be
stuck repeating talking points with no
deal in sight you got real from
government first we're gonna have a wall
we're gonna have a barrier the gridlock
is causing hardship in homes across the
country father we pray that this will be
resolved one Texas church turned to
prayer as families faced a week without
a paycheck when you don't get your your
paycheck it starts putting you behind
Tawana smith from Pasadena Maryland says
her family is making tough choices while
her husband is furloughed we have to
decide which builders we're gonna pay
how much we're going to spend when it
comes to any loan payments or credit
card payments the government has also
stopped providing loans to small
business owners reducing capital by
about 90 million dollars a day and
stopped granting some permits so even
craft beer makers are feeling the pinch
we've seen this in the past when they've
been short-handed and
and it can get to the point where those
approvals take a long time but for most
the worry is putting food on the table
food banks are opening their doors while
they still have funding we'll be here
for our communities as long as they need
us the White House is considering going
around House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer and
negotiating directly with rank-and-file
democrats but last night after a
bipartisan group of senators met there
was very little progress that would be
made hence so far there is no end in
sight Nora
all right Paula Reid at the White House
thank you so much